qué podemos esperar sobre la jornada
electoral sin participación de la
mayoría de la oposición es probable que
nicolás maduro y su partido tomen el
control de la asamblea nacional
si definitivamente estas elecciones no
serán libres y justas y el psv para
reclamar una contundente victoria esto
sin duda va a debilitar a la posesión
sin importarse a condenados por los
críticos nacionales o internacionales de
maduro
además parece ser un paso más hacia un
estado de partido único similar a rusia
o incluso a cuba o chino
pese a estas pese a las sanciones y al
reconocimiento internacional de juan
guaidó la oposición parece ir quedando
cada vez menos con menos opciones que
perspectiva de para venezuela después de
estas elecciones
temo que estamos viendo los últimos
vestigios de la democracia en el país
considerando que la asamblea nacional es
la única institución estatal controlada
por la oposición definitivamente puede
ser también un paso más hacia un
gobierno en exilio lo cual sería
una victoria para el chavismo
efectivamente además lo que estamos
viendo es la consolidación del poder del
plasma duro tanto ante la oposición como
dentro del chavismo podríamos esperar
más sanciones internacionales en esta
tras los resultados de estas elecciones
que si le dan una victoria a nicolás
maduro creo que sí pero sanciones en
multilaterales
considerando la nueva administración de
joe biden en los 200